there is little choice for many in
ukraine but to make this journey fleeing
their homes as the shelling continues in
the hope of finding safe haven in a
place like bilirodka
they pack up whatever they can the lucky
ones to make it through one of the
humanitarian corridors out of the terror
of the fighting in towns near the
capital kiev
yesterday
we
go
with a russian
russian army
through the um through the park or where
there are there are
russian soldiers or which is
which
killed people
and the scale of this exodus is
astonishing
this is the fourth day we have organised
such a headquarters here
in four days more than 25 000 people
have left mostly from the jottemere
direction
it's urpin booker
today we went to boro dianca nimachevo
we are waiting for the buses with our
people from there
and the russian bombardment continues to
be focused on the population centers as
throughout this war satellite images
continue to tell a chilling story fires
burning apartment buildings destroyed
this is zelenskivo street in mariopol
before the shelling
and after
whatever the debate about the
effectiveness of the russian assault the
destruction of sites like this hospital
is evident
in the city of malitapol where the mayor
was detained by russian forces on friday
a new mayor has reportedly been
installed the city is under russian
control president zielenski warned that
russia would try to impose its own
choice of leader in occupied territories
the invaders in the kirsan region are
trying to repeat the notorious
experience of the formation of
pseudo-republics blackmail local leaders
put pressure on deputies look for
someone to bribe
the us has announced it's sending
another 200 million dollars worth of
military equipment
russia's invasion
threatens
not just ukraine's democracy
it threatens democracy and security
across
europe
and by extension when democracy is
threatened anywhere
it threatens
us all
millions of ukrainians have already left
these children being treated for cancer
boarding a medical train over the border
in poland
none of them knowing exactly when
they'll ever be able to make that
journey home again greg milam sky news